Thanks for calling the Magic Castle, it's Amber. Yeah sure do, 38 dollars a night.
Okay, I warned you one drip and you're out.
Oh come on!
Out now.
It's gonna melt outside.
It's melting inside too.
But Bobby
Out.
Thank you very much
You're not welcome!
The man who lives in here gets arrested a lot
These are the rooms we're not supposed to go in but let's go anyway!
Could you give us some change please?
The doctor said we have asthma and we gotta eat ice cream right away
Here you go
Halley, we've got a situation here open up
It's only second week of the summer, and there's already been a dead fish in the pool
We were trying to get it back alive.
Water balloons thrown at tourists.
I failed as a mother Moonee
Yeah Mom you're a disgrace
New job? Yeah. If you're working who's looking after Moonee?
You're not my father!
I don't want to be your father.
You can't treat me like this!
You don't think everybody knows what's up Halley? Everybody.
She's about to cry. I can always tell when adults are about to cry.
Why is my mum yelling? They're just talking, they gotta figure something out.
See! I took you on a safari.
Woah, let's go. Come on!
Have a nice day
Love you Bobby!
I love you, too